you
[Music]
women on television in local news they
have really cool like Rent the Runway
dresses they're beautiful
they know how to do their makeup like
they were born to know they have lots of
earrings and tall shoes I wanted to be
them my whole life because if I got to
be them or look like them that was the
ultimate Hall Pass
I could just tell stories and I maxed
out a lot of credit cards trying to look
like that but this is the one we've all
been waiting for
it just didn't work good evening I'm
Janice short o thank you for joining us
you can't have an authentic voice if you
feel like you're in a costume
he's a long time but I did find a way to
unapologetically be myself
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Janice Shortell I'm a
journalist and I host a show here at
kare 11 in Minneapolis Minnesota are you
guys excited when I first moved to
Minneapolis 15 years ago I was not out I
didn't see anyone succeeding in front of
a camera as a gay woman you know I
remember being a little kid when Ellen
came out and it didn't go well Rachel
Maddow wasn't on TV back then so I
swallowed it the first thing I did when
I moved here was get a boyfriend and
he's great I haven't really seen him in
15 years I still like you Craig I was
actively internally fighting the fact
that I was gay it was like being two
people at once
but you can only do that for so long as
a girl growing up in the world there was
a code
and in this industry at least the code
was very easy to see and follow pretty
hair perfect makeup and their outfits
look like they do in the magazines look
at my face look at my face look oh
there's no lesbian smirk yet that was
internally difficult but I knew how to
do it so in my late 20s I started coming
out a little bit at a time I'm not out
on air and when I would have to be on
this side of the camera I got so scared
it was where I was least confident
because I would have to do stuff to look
like somebody I wasn't and how can you
authentically present the news or
someone's story when you're terrified
someone said cut your hair this isn't
working it went from Bob to short by
Kimberly Kimberly Kim helped me to
become Who I am I've been doing Jana's
hair for her about 15 years when I first
met her she needed a beautifully
executed masterful bob but I would style
her hair differently in order to go out
with friends then we what if she was
going back to work and the two became
very separate it was - Jana's and for me
it was overwhelming because it was two
clients we work together to help her
evolve in to what is now her most
comfortable personal style as she was
assigned this new project in this new
show it became more evident to me that
that was what they were wanting to see
they were wanting to see more of her and
so I absolutely was banging a tambourine
and trying to cheer her on and trying to
move it right along
I loved her coming-out story I think
it's beautiful
when we debuted this show on January
11th of 2016 I felt confident enough to
wear this hair and a David Bowie t-shirt
and I was so scared that the minute I
got off there would be like this group
of people are gonna beat me up or like
it send me mail did say take her off the
air none of that happened the applause
were there I wasn't saying I'm going to
be this like trailblazer I'm just me I
mean this is always who I've been
I'm sad that I'm some sort of anomaly it
seems goofy cuz I know a lot of people
that look like me but I'm sure you could
call news directors all over the country
that would say my hair's problem
we all know the heartbreaking stories
about what happens in the LGBTQ
community to kids figuring out where you
belong
and I will be damned if I am not the
person that they need me to be to get
them to that point where they see
themselves and say help
you
I'm Eric Mason I'm a mother and I'm a
transgender guy Koree is my 15 year old
transgender daughter I started
transitioning almost two years ago and
Corey started transitioning almost five
years ago I've always known that I was
different
I've always known that I'm not the
normal boy I was never like tapi I was
always negative and when I first put on
some makeup I was like my family is made
up of me my husband and my five children
I waited until Cory was completely
through her transition before I came out
myself it was really hard keeping that
secret from my family especially for my
husband but at the time I just knew I
had to focus on my child
I've been boy since fifth grade and
still getting bald sometimes when kids
said I should you go and kill myself
because that I was different
[Music]
when my mom came out I was like I'm not
alone anymore we can actually understand
what we're going through with each other
we can you know talk to each other for
having a bad day me supporting Cory is
in my opinion what you're supposed to do
as a parent you're supposed to support
your children no matter what so I don't
feel like I did anything special I
didn't I just love my kid I love my kid
no matter what she looks like
no matter who she wants to be we are
stronger as a family I think anytime you
are living your authentic self and you
are living your truth it makes you a
better person overall it makes you a
better parent and makes you a better
spouse my family is everything we fight
we laugh we cry we're a typical family
we just look a little different that's
it all boils down to
[Music]
it was 1972 love was in the air and a
pair of scientists made a discovery that
serendipitously made them legends in the
pride movement meet Siebert biologists
and oceanographer George hunt
hi I'm George hunt and his partner at
the time Molly I'm Molly Warner in 1972
they were doing research on the behavior
of Western gulls off the coast of Santa
Barbara one day Molly called me to let
me know she'd found something really
unexpected
we had to mark territories and nests to
look at how the eggs were laid and we
found extra eggs than we expected this
shocking discovery puzzled them somehow
these nests had more eggs than a single
female could lay per day direction of
the study switched to try and figure out
what was going on over the next year and
a half they spent more time with these
goals and discovered two female birds
were acting as a mated pair they shared
a nest and raise their young together to
our knowledge this was the first
instance of homosexuality in a wild
population they went on to publish their
findings in an international scientific
journal the response was overwhelming
I had phone calls from New York Times
Times of India London time
one of the Australian newspapers and it
even ended up in places like Playboy
unfortunately there was a lot of
backlash to homosexuality in 1970s
America was still misunderstood people
felt angry toward us and the research we
did and they even worked hard to try and
get Congress to slow down the funding it
was a strange time in Seigle research
but then something else happened farmers
started to send letters to they said if
I spend any time in a forum I would know
that farm animals are often the same sex
baby turns out their findings were not
all that radical today hundreds of
different animal species have been found
exhibit homosexual behavior it was
natural it had a really big impact on
the arguments against homosexuality that
said it doesn't occur in nature and
therefore it's against God's will the
homosexual pairing has very little to do
with morality as far as the gulls are
concerned George and Molly received
letters postcards and phone calls from
members of the LGBT community thanking
them for their bravery this research
transcended into music cartoons and even
plays that's the best you can hope for
in science is that a piece of work is
used by other scientists and a really
big bonus is if it makes a difference to
the people of a nation
[Music]